aquí tenemos 5 rectángulos y en este
rectángulo en amarillo nos dan dos
pedazos de información 1 que la altura
es 10 y otro que el área es 60 bueno a
partir de esta información y de todos
estos numeritos que acompañan a los
otros rectángulos lo que quiero que
hagas ahorita es que pausas el vídeo y
pienses cuáles de estos rectángulos
tienen el mismo perímetro o la misma
área que este rectángulo de acá entonces
pausa el vídeo piénsalo tantito y cuando
estés listo dale continuar muy bien
vamos a empezar a resolver el problema
si queremos saber cuáles de estos
rectángulos tienen el mismo perímetro o
la misma área entonces sería bueno
conocer el perímetro y el área de todos
ellos vamos a calcular eso déjame
empezar con este que es el principal en
este nos dicen que la altura es 10 y que
el área es 60 nos falta determinar el
perímetro cómo le podemos hacer para
encontrar el perímetro bueno pues nos
faltaría encontrar la medida de este
lado por ejemplo conociendo la medida de
este lado tenemos el de este y él
este y podemos encontrar el perímetro y
eso lo podemos encontrar porque nos
dicen que el área es 60 y ya tenemos uno
de los lados entonces para que el área
nos dé sesenta tenemos que multiplicar
diez por algo 10 por ese algo debe dar
60 y ese algo debe ser 6
de este modo este lado mide 6 este lado
mide 10 este lado mide 6 no importa qué
unidades estemos usando y con esto
podemos determinar el perímetro le voy a
poner aquí arriba perímetro peri metro
para calcular el perímetro simplemente
sumamos 10 + 6 16 más 10 626 + 10 es 32
muy bien con esto tenemos que el
perímetro de este rectángulo es 32 vamos
ahora a este rectángulo de acá acá lo
que nos dan es el perímetro y tenemos
que encontrar su área también nos da en
este lado de acá como le podemos hacer
para encontrar el otro lado eso sería
muy útil para encontrar este lado de acá
bueno pues no tenemos qué sucede si
sumamos este lado de acá con este lado
de acá eso sería recorrer la mitad del
perímetro porque este lado es igual a
este y este es igual a este entonces
este lado más este lado debe ser igual a
la mitad del perímetro osea a 17 si éste
ya mide 55 para 17 es 12 y por lo tanto
este lado de acá mide 12 y con esta
información ya podemos determinar el
área que voy a poner aquí el área
para determinar el área simplemente
ahora multiplicamos 5 por 12 5 por 12 es
60 vamos a empezar a empezar a comparar
a ver el área de 60 que es la misma que
este de acá tienen la misma área
pero el perímetro de este lado es 34 y
de este lado es 32 entonces tienen
diferente perímetro vale misma área
diferente perímetro vamos ahora a este
rectángulo de acá este rectángulo más
bien es un cuadrado verdad porque tiene
dos lados iguales de 8 y de 8 entonces
este de acá también mide 8 y este de acá
también mide 8 y con esto ya podemos
calcular su área y su perímetro para
calcular el área el área
simplemente multiplicamos 8 por 8 es 64
nos quedaría 64 unidades cuadradas vale
y el perímetro del perímetro
y metro sería sumar todos sus lados o
bien darnos cuenta que es 4 veces 8 y 4
por 8 es igual a 32 32 entonces tiene el
mismo perímetro 32 pero tiene diferente
área muy bien pasemos ahora a este
rectángulo azul misma idea en este
rectángulo azul para calcular el área el
área
simplemente multiplicamos 4 por 15 4 por
15 es 60 y para calcular el perímetro
perímetro usamos que es un rectángulo de
modo que este lado mide 4 este mide 15 y
entonces hacemos 4 15 19 + 4 es 23 + 15
es 38 entonces el perímetro sería 38 38
unidades tiene la misma área que el
rectángulo amarillo pero diferente
perímetro y finalmente tenemos este
rectángulo de acá que es color digamos
rosa mexicano en el cual tenemos que
hacer lo mismo que hemos hecho en estos
últimos 2 vamos a calcular su área para
calcular el área el área
simplemente multiplicamos 10 por 20 que
sería 200 200 unidades cuadradas no
importa cuáles sean y para calcular el
perímetro pues vamos a hacerlo de una
forma un poquito más interesante
bueno es exactamente lo mismo que hemos
hecho
y va a ser lo siguiente hacemos 10 + 20
que es 30 y eso es la mitad del camino
porque esta es igual a este 10 + vende
es 10 + 20 es 30 y 30 por 12 60 entonces
el perímetro es 60 el área es distinta y
el perímetro también es distinto nos
queda un 60 pero no estamos comparando
área con perímetro verdad sino perímetro
con perímetro y entonces el perímetro
también es distinto